i'm so in shock at this place it is the
biggest disgrace
known to man viewed close to two million
times this seething rant about toronto's
pearson airport from a former nhl player
is echoing far and wide at a time when
canada's tourism industry needs a boost
there is a 400 person line with two air
canada workers so i wait in that line
about six hours be it near the end of
the line
they closed it they just said oh you
have to go somewhere else are you just
running a security line extreme delays
have frustrated passengers finally
trying to vacation for weeks i'm hoping
that i don't miss my flight so far i'm
okay that's why we came early today you
need to be prepared and you need to be
flexible we're making sure that we're
not booking people on tight connections
while the problems are mostly at pearson
they affect travelers across canada
that's our gateway to europe it's our
gateway to the caribbean and so i'm
having to talk with clients every day
they're weighing the pros and cons of
should we go on this trip to the
caribbean because do we actually want to
travel through toronto pearson blames
passengers being held on planes 53
percent in the last week of may and
calls on the federal government to drop
inbound public health requirements we
could go back to pre-covered normal that
would have a huge impact but then hiring
more staff to uh to be able to work
security would be obviously very helpful
it was something we could have predicted
and the government should have moved
earlier this is a global context having
said that we have to do something the
transport minister says security weights
are improving but can't say when
everything will be fixed calling it
gradual airline companies have not
returned to full schedule yet
there are still some employees labor
shortages issue
there are some process issues another
equally pressing problem passport
renewal delays the government blames an
unprecedented surge in demand the
opposition says it was totally
predictable service canada hired an
extra 600 people and plans to double
that in the next several weeks and
reassign 600 more with passport
experience but there's no clear answer
as to how soon the backlog will be
cleared with the summer travel season on
our doorstep chris
all right abigail thank you that's
abigail beeman in ottawa